you're going on a journey
a journey through memory all you have to
do is follow my voice
[Music]
we're closed i know i'm sorry it's late
we have time for one more job
when the waters began to rise and war
broke out
[Music]
nostalgia became a way of life
there wasn't a lot to look forward to
some people began looking back
nothing is more addictive than the past
no no no no don't put me back
put me back i understand
she's moved on and you should too people
don't just
vanish to find where she'd gone i had to
know where she'd been
or she running from the past
or racing back towards it
how much did you really know her how
much did you love
i'm washing you're watching me not with
me
you think you are nervous or you don't
mercy where is he
[Music]
arson bribery murder
[Applause]
i've turned a blind eye to plenty i have
to do this
[Music]
that machine of yours how close can you
get
before the illusion's broken
you're going on a journey all you have
to do is follow my voice
[Music]
you